(playful music)
- [Voiceover] So my daughter just told me
she uses my toothbrush
to brush the dog's teeth.
How's your day going?
- [Voiceover] The kids
walked in on me and my wife
wrestling again.
My son said, "Mommy should stop
'cause it always sounds
like she's losing."
- [Voiceover] My
four-year-old just told me,
"It's okay, I love you,
so I might not put you
in the washing machine tonight."
- [Voiceover] My son just said
I have a comforting forehead.
Weirdest compliment ever.
- [Voiceover] Turned 26 today.
My son told me I'm old like
a tree and gonna die soon.
- [Voiceover] My five-year-old
just asked my three-year-old
to step into her office.
She concluded the conversation with,
"And remember, my door is always open."
- [Voiceover] I went to see
a mortgage advisor with my
seven-year-old son, and when we sat down
across from his desk, my son
said, "I'm not her husband."
- [Voiceover] My son said, "Mommy,
you are a terrible cook,
but I eat your food because I love you,
and I don't want to hurt your feelings.
But, I don't want to die either."
- [Voiceover] My young son
just told me he wants to be a
hooker when he's older.
He meant fisherman.
- [Voiceover] My daughter told
me the moon was a stalker,
and I asked why.
She said, "Because it's
always following me."
- [Voiceover] My son ran out
of my bedroom waving my blue
vibrator in the air, yelling,
"Look at my new lightsaber!"
Why do these things happen
when the neighbors are over?
(playful music)